それではよろしくお願いします
今日のテーマに入ります
えーと 今日のテーマは大変非常に珍しいブッダの暴力論ですね
ですから皆様も仏教で正しくいかに暴力振るった方がいいのかということを学ぶために来たでしょうと思いますけどね
えーと まあどうかなとわかりません
仏教はね 一切の生命に対して慈しみを説く教えなんですよ
怒り 憎しみの根絶を推薦する教えですね
ですので 仏教には暴力論がありません
最初からちょっとあべこべなんです
仏教の暴力論と言ったって
そんなのは全くも存在すらしないんです
しかし 釈尊は最初の師匠であり
浄業と何とかなんと言いますね
浄業浄でしたっけ 人々を浄化することによってはね
ものすごい素晴らしい能力を発揮しているんですね
ブッダの教えからどのように人を育てるべきなのかということは学びます
だから暴力論ではなくて
我々はどうしたら人々を育ちますかということはね
それは学びます はい で
今日のテーマはもうそういう話題目次がありまして
これは私の私の脳細胞の中のからくりですから
別に理解できなくても結構一向に構わないんですね
で まずこのベーシックベーシックキャラクターリスティックオブオールインベースというテーマに行って
それからバイオレンス among リビングベースというところに行って
それからバイオレンス among ヒューマンズというところで
それからプログレッシブプログレス is オブリゲーションというテーマに入ります
それから How to train man to be a man of dignity, morals, rationali
ty, and wisdom
というテーマに入ります
それから 成長の過程 ホモサピエンスからソーシャルマン
それからマンオブモラルアンドディグニティ
それからスーパーマンインパーソナリティという順番で人は成長するんだというのは今日の目次なんですね
よくわからないんだから次に行きましょうか
はい まずブッダの言葉から始まります
であんまり苦労しなかったんですね
今日はね 昨日講演がありましたからね
それも結構苦労しなかったから
今日よりよく喋りましたので
まあ一応みんな知っているパーリ経典から例を出しますね
暴力についてお釈迦様の言葉ですね
サッビータサンティダンダッス
生命は体罰に怯えるんですね
サッビーというのはすべてのなんです
それはすべての生命はですね
体罰に怯える サッベーバーヤンティマッチュナ
生命は死をまた怯えるんですね
震えるんです まあ上は震えるでね
怯えるんですよ 死は怖いんですね
どんな生命にしても アッターナンウパマンカトワ
自分を例として考えて
ね アニーエナガアと言い
他をいじめてはならない
殺してはならない だから自分のことを考えてよと
お釈迦様はおっしゃっているんです
自分が体罰はこう震えるでしょ
嫌でしょう 死は怖いでしょう
だからそれを他人に与えてはいけませんという教えですね
これ ダンマパダの百二十九という偈ですね
これで断言的にブッダは暴力に反対ということはよくわかると思います
また 続きの同じ偈の続きがございまして
サッベータサンティダンラスサッベーサンジービタンピアン
生命は体罰に震える 生命は自分の命を好む
前は死は怖がる 怯える
今度は命は好むのです
生きていきたいんですね
アッターナンウパマンカトワナニーエナガアとい
自分を霊として考えて
他をいじめないこと 殺さないこと
残酷ですよ 自分自身が体罰に震えるし
命がすごく欲しいと思っているしね
生きていきたいと だったら他人
他の生命からそれを奪うなよと
奪うんではなくてね その自分が怖いものを
嫌がるものを与えてはいけませんと
与えたものは返ってくるんだからね
ですから 他の破壊っていうのは自己破壊なんですね
仏教ですごい軽々く みんなこの布施とかね
あれやこれやと言ってますけど
言論とかね だから布施の場合は与える行為なんですね
これがただものを与えるという随分楽な解説しますけど
そうじゃないんです 自分があらゆるものを与えているんですね
他の生命に ね 例えば言葉を喋ったということはどういうこと？独り言ではなくてね
言葉を喋ったっていうことは
何か他人に与えたんですよ
そこで人間同士だったら言葉を与えたら言葉が返ってくる場合はありますけど
実際の与えることと それからその見返りで得るものっていうのはそういうものじゃないんですね
精神的に与えたものが自分の精神に同じものだから返ってくるんですね
大体返ってくる場合はかなり強烈になって返ってくるんです
だから我々は人をいじめるっていうことは
その人にものすごい嫌な気持ちを与えることなんですね
だからこれは必ず自分に同じもの
倍になって 何倍もなって返ってくるんです
なんで倍に何倍になるかというと
例えば私はある人にね
これは馬鹿野郎とか言ったら瞬間の出来事なんですね
でも 言われた人の心にそれは残るんですね
脳細胞の脳に残って どんどんその嫌なものを繁殖するんですね
その度に私の責任なんですよ
なんかすごい不公平な仕組みのように感じるかもしれませんだけど
ね 例えば私はバカやこの野郎と言ったところで
その人はどんどんどんどんそこはすごい傷跡をね
もう大きくして大きくして
いても立ってもいられなくなっちゃって自殺でもしましょう
だから遊びじゃないんですよ
だから私が言った言葉でしょ
このきっかけになったのは
だから業は甘く見ない方が
いいんです これ自己管理できるものもあってできないんですね
法則というんです お釈迦様は
地球の引力 なんだらかんだらというの法則でしょう
どうにもならない そんなようなものなんですね
それで お釈迦様は明確に答えを出しています
各生命が体罰は震える
嫌がる 自分はものすごく怖がる
自分の命をものすごく愛している
だから自分でもそれ知ってるでしょうに
自分のことで それだけ与えてはいけませんと
この絶対的に嫌なものをね
自分が壊れてしまいます
だから他の破壊は自己破壊なんですね
スカカマーニブータニヨーダンレーナヴィンサティアットノースカメサーノーペッチャソーナラバティスカン
ですから お釈迦様 この法則を本当にわかりやすく言うんですね
幸福 楽を好む生命を武器でいじめるならば
幸福 楽を好む自分が後
いわゆる死後ですね 幸福
楽を得られないんだと
自分が貯金しているものは違いますから
不幸 体罰を貯金しているんですね
それで死後はそれが素晴らしい幸福になって帰るわけじゃないんです
そこでアットノースカメサンという文章がございましてね
生命は楽になりたいと思っているんです
楽になりたいと思って体罰を与えるんです
ずいぶんいい加減なんです
学校やらね 学校のいじめも体罰も
学校にあるいじめも 会社のいじめも
このいじめる側が楽をしたいんですね
他に与える痛み 苦しみの経験は自分も受けることになるんです
はい 次のタイトルに行きます
幸福を期待するなら  スカカマーニブータニヨーダンレーナナヒンサティアットノースカメサーノーペッチャソーラバティスカン
幸福 楽を好む生命を武器でいじめない人は
自分が期待する幸福に達するのです
だから私が幸福になりたいと思うならば
他の生命にいかなる暴力も振るわないこと
ものすごく気をつけることです
自分を愛するならば わかりやすく言えば他を愛しなさいなんですよ
体罰を与えたいという感情が湧き上がっても
時々嫌なやつらがいるんだから
体罰を与えたくなっちゃいますね
その気持ち 感情が湧き上がっても
その気持ち 相手を慈しむことで制御します
怒りたくなっても制御します
慈しみに怒鳴りたくなっても制御します
これ 自分がすごいエネルギー場を作っているんですよ
そのことで たったそれだけで
何も特別に見えることを何もやってないんです
外で派手に見えるものは
ただ なんか怒りがこみ上げてきちゃっただけなんです
それで自分で慈しみでこいつに対して怒っちゃったんだけど
でもこの人はやっぱり幸せに生活したいし
私はこの人の破滅を期待しているわけじゃないしね
だからまあどうしようもないもう
ということで 自分の怒りを消すんですね
このエネルギーなんですよ
自分の幸福になるの この頑張った分
この業のエネルギーは自分に幸福をもたらします
だからみんななんか変なことを考えていますね
もう何のことなく 毎日すごい良い徳を積むことできますね
自分の感情を 悪い感情をそろそろそろそろ潰してみます
すごい精神的なパワーが溜まっていきますよ
いきなり怒るなかよっていう風なことじゃないんです
怒りがこみ上げてきたら
さっさとコラっと言ってことで
さっさとその日で水で消してみる
その日を そのこみ上げてきた怒りの炎を消したことが
自分に対してすごいいいことをしたことになっちゃうんです
で 暴力っていうのはいろいろありますね
言葉の暴力もありますね
マーオーセパルサンカンチ
ブッダパティバディユタン
ドゥッカヒサランベカタ
パティダンラプセイユタン
粗悪語を語るのこと 似た言葉が返ってくる
言い争いは苦しいのです
殴ると殴られるということ
殴ると殴られるのです
だからやめましょうよと
やめましょうという言葉がこの一行のマなんですね
マ ドント ストップ マっていうのはパーリ語でドントというね
ストップという言葉の意味なんですね
それでアウォチェで言わない方がいいだろうと
だから私個人としてはもう悪口言いたいんですね
気楽ですね 言う時は人を怒鳴ったり
悪口言ったり もう愚痴を吐いたり
いろんなことを言うと気分がいいんでしょ
これでどうなるか 自分が吐いてるだけで
何のも修行も何のエネルギーも貯まらないんですね
だからそのエネルギーを内面で別のエネルギーで消して消して消していくことことが
我々の精神的な成長になるんです
自分が他の生命に与える感覚が自分にも返ってくるんです
だから粗悪語っていうのは
自分が頭の中でイライラしていてね
怒って それで乱暴な言葉使ってますね
殴ったと同じことなんですよ
しかし 殴ったよりは粗悪語の方が罪が重いんです
なぜならば 殴ったら相手に相手には感じられる痛みにはリミットがあるんです
私は人をぶん殴る その人はものすごい痛くなる
しかし その痛みは 大きくならないんです
殴ったらどの程度の力が体に入ったのか
それから体格によっても
若い筋肉のある男性だったら
殴ったっても筋肉が反発するんだから
何のこともなくゴムみたいに痛くないんです
しかし 子供や年寄りを殴っちゃうと
筋肉はゴミのようにフンと反発してこないんですね
これが相当痛いんです
しかし その痛みはある程度なんですね
それから殴った瞬間から痛みがどんどんどんどんどんどん減っていくんです
増えるということはないんです
じゃあ人を言葉で貶してみて下さい
リミットわからないでしょう
せいぜいリミットは自分の言語能力と相手が
何パーセント受け取るのかっていうところで制限されます
大体人間というのは人が喋ってもね
全部聞いてないでしょう
まあ私の場合は 0.1パーセントしか聞いてなさそうですけど
まあ他の人が喋るの大体まあほぼ 50パーセントですね
せいぜい真面目に聞いたってもね
残りは聞いてないんです
ですから 喋る場合は 相手がどれぐらい量を受け取るか
私の言語能力はどれぐらいかっていうことによって
ちょっと制限はありますけど
一旦受け取ってから この悪口をね
自分を侮辱したこと 自分を冒涜したこと
心に入ってから その人はどれぐらい悩むのかっていうことは知ったものじゃないんですね
それでなんか逆法則があるんですよ
で 私がものすごいひどい冒涜
侮辱の言葉を喋っても
相手があっけらかんとニコニコと
全然受けない 微塵も痛みを感じない場合はどうなるのかと
だから私はなんか何も与えてないようになってるでしょ
私は与えたんだけど その人の心がもう受けてないんですね
それだったら罪にならないでしょ
罪になるのは相手が困った時でしょ
これが違うんですね その場合はものすごいランク上の罪になるんです
侮辱して侮辱される だから侮辱されて苦しんでる人が受けた苦しみは
私は受ける権利がありますね
そちらのトップランク上になるんですよ
なんか難しくなりました
人の悪い言葉をそのまま受ける人ならば
受ける量が人によって様々でしょ
聞く量も様々でしょ では推測しましょう
ある人が言った言葉を 100パーセント聞いて受け取った
この悪い言葉を 侮辱の言葉を 100パーセント聞いて受け取って
完璧に悩みました これ以上人間には悩むことは不可能
というリミットを推測しましょう
もし相手が全然ニコニコで
いくら侮辱しても受け取らない精神状態にいるならば
私の罪はその一番上のあのレベルから計算されます
数字で言えばわかるかもしれません
人を侮辱されると 例えば123ポイントでポイントで上がると思いましょう
しかし 侮辱を受けないできた人を侮辱すると
いきなりポイントは 100 200 400
で上がっていっちゃうんです
そういうわけで まあ言葉の暴力も体の暴力よりはひどいんです
罪は重いんです 感覚 気持ちを中心にして理解した方がよろしい
ですから 我々は業ということを与えるという
仏教の布施という仏教の善行為などをね
で この感覚ということで理解できます
理解してください 私は何を感じるのかということは
私の業なんですね だから
各人の感覚違うでしょ
で 例えばね バナナ 1本ね 2
人で割って食べてもね
バナナですからね 味が同じですよ
しかし その食べる時 どんな楽しみ感じるのかっていうことは
これは同じじゃないんです
私がバナナを食べて感じる楽しみを相手に与えられませんね
相手にバナナは与えられます
で 相手はバナナ半分は食べて楽しみを感じます
そういうわけで 各個人がどの程度で感覚感じるのかっていうことは
もうバラバラで何の共通点もないんです
するところは それが業というんです
例えばいろいろ言われてはいるんだけど
明るくいる人がいるでしょ
その人の業がいいんですね
ちょっとしたことでひどく悩む人がいるでしょ
やっぱり業が悪いんですよ
例えば学校で結構 からかわれたり
悪口言われたりするんですけど
あの子はそれをあんまり気にしないで
へっちゃらで学校で生きている
その子の業が強いんですね
しかし ある学校でみんな行儀が良くて
いじめもなくて からかうこともなくて
うまくいってるんだけど
まあちょこちょこっと言葉のあやで言葉をちょっと間違ってしまっただけで
ある子供がガクンとそれ気になって落ち込んでしまったら
ちょっとしたことで やっぱりそれが業が弱いんですね
これは誰にも何の管理もできないんです
一人一人がどの程度この世の中を感じるのかっていうことは
まあ決まっている 決まっているというのはおかしい言葉なんですけど
個人個人別なんです これは皆様毎日知っていることでしょう
皆様が楽しんだからって
その楽しみを犬にも与えますって言ったっても
これはちょっと難しい
犬が楽しがっているんだから
私も同じように楽しみましょうと思ったっても
これ難しい 自分の楽しみは自分のもので
犬の楽しみ楽しみは犬のもので
これは交換できません
仏教で業っていうのはそういうものなんですね
業の一部ですけど だから世の中のことはこの業で考えた方が道徳は成り立ちます
あの殴るということは別に悪い行為とは言えませんよ
何を与えるのかと 子供たちはじゃれてじゃれて遊んでいる時は殴り合いもするでしょ
でもそれは子供たちの遊びであって
で 殴る側も殴られる側も結構楽しくやっているんですね
で それを見ていると たまに業が弱い子がこのすぐ怒ったり
腹が立ったりする これで遊びが遊びでなくなっちゃうんです
ですから これ業がかかってくるんですね
自分が痛くなっちゃって
殴られて それで怒ってきたら
自分がかなり暗くなっていくんですね
自分もそういう業なんですね
それで レスリング同士でね
ボクサー同士で殴り合う時は当然痛いとは思いますよ
痛くない？よくわからない
みんな喜んでいるんですけど
私は見ないんですからね
そういうのは  はい ものすごく痛いでしょう
ボクサーにやられるとね
あれが悪業にならないね
面白いことに 暴力ということじゃないんですよ
だから肉体が痛い それはその人の業なんです
それはもう業の果報だから
それで消えて消えていくだけ
しかし やられたボクサーがどんどん怒り
嫉妬 憎しみを作っちゃうと
自分が新たな悪業を作っていることになっちゃうんです
で 感覚中心に気持ち中心に物事を考えてください
人を殴ったということで何か与えたんだけど
それが業ではなくて その人の気持ちどうなったのかと
その人飛び上がって飛び上がって楽しがったら
私は楽しみを与えているんです
すごく悲しくなったら
私は悲しみを与える与えているんですね
だから相手が感じたものですよ
業 だから相手に感じさせたものは
自分がまた何千倍もなって受け取ることになっちゃうんです
はい そういうわけで 類で対反応しないというテーマで
サチネレシアッターナンカンソーパアトーヤターエサパットーシニッバーナンサーランブーテーナインジャティ
えーと これ何でしたっけ？ヒビが入った鐘のように
自己を戒めるならば その人こそが安穏に達しているのです
その心には張り合うの気持ちは存在しない
で 鐘っていうのはね ちょっと触っただけですごい反応するんですね
ちょっと指でこうやって引いただけでも
結構 もしちょっとしたヒビがあったらどう？音がそれで終わっちゃうんですね
心はそういうふりしてほしいとお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんです
ヒビが入った鐘のように
これどういうことかというと
人々が不完全で悪業を言うんですよ
悪口言うんですね 悪口言っても自分が同じあれ
反応はしない この鐘がヒビが入っているんです
で 皆様は立派な鐘持ってますから
人がちょっとだけあなたはね
言っただけでも怒ってるでしょ
結構なんかアンプがすごい強力なアンプ付いてるみたいですね
人はそこまで言うつもりはなかったんだけどね
ちょっと冗談っぽくてね
あんたね 本当にどう見たっておかしいやと言ったら
この人がおかしいって言われた
なんだこれはとかね ものすごく興奮して怒っちゃったら
これはもうもう 1 万ワットぐらいの出力あるアンプ付いてるんですね
同じことを類で反応するんですね
怒りに怒りで 欲に欲に欲で
これやめなさいよと やめることをできた人は阿羅漢に立ってますよ
エサパットーシニッバーナ
その人こそ涅槃に達していますよと
自分の心が類で反応しないようになっちゃった
いわゆるひび割れが入りました
人は怒りに怒りで いじめにいじめで類で反応する
心を育てた人は類で反応しない
これは 134番目の偈ですね
非暴力主義者に暴力を振ると
で さらにお釈迦様は注意するんですね
世の中でもう非暴力に達した人
人がいるんですよ 心の汚れの恐ろしい業の鐘
輪廻の鐘にヒビが入った方々がいるんです
いくらこちら怒鳴っても
向こうは怒らない 怒れない
私はいくら相手のことを憎んでも
相手の方が憎めない精神です
ヒビが入っているんです
あの業の鐘に その方々に暴力を振るのは至って簡単
だって何も返してくれないんだから
殴っても殴り返してくれない
捕まって足なんか切断したっても何もいない
言えません それだったらやりたい放題でしょ
そうしたらどうなるのかというと
お釈迦様がすぐさま 10種類の不幸に陥ると説くんです 1
激しい苦しみ 与えた人は生きるんですね
体が壊れるんです 3 重病にかかる 4
心が狂う 5 財産は王に取られる
昔は王 今は政府没収されます 6
激しい非難を受ける 7
親族が減るっていうのは出ていきます
日本の社会でも 誰かの家族で犯罪を起こしたら
他の親戚も親戚関係やめちゃってなんか引いていくでしょう
8 財産は分散する なくなってしまいます 9
家は火にあう 10 愚か者が死後地獄に落ちる
この地獄という言葉を釈迦さ使うのは
これはたくさんないんです
不幸に陥ると書くんだけ
教えるだけで この場合はあえて地獄に落ちるという言葉なんです
これもダンマだからです
暴力は自分の都合なんです
それでブッダの立場は
暴力はもう断然ダメです
もう成り立たないものなんです
もう信じられない 暴力振るってあなた大丈夫なのかと
人を怒鳴って人に怒って
人に体罰を与えて あなた自身が大丈夫なのかと
これが自分の都合ですね
暴力振る人は 自分にとって楽な道を選んでいるのです
何でも楽に早く済ませたいと思う
落ち着き 忍耐のない性格なんです
だから楽ですよ 殴った方が
暴力は自分が楽になる早道だと勘違いです
暴力者のこの精神的な未熟さを踏まえて
釈尊は幸福楽を期待するなら暴力をやめることだと非暴力の正しい道を説かれるんです
ですから お釈迦様がこの暴力を振るっている人々
加害者たちの気持ちを理解したのですね
この加害者たちが 楽になりたいんですよ
例えば子供 学校の子供たちはなかなか授業に集中してくれない
まあサバサバしている
立ったり座ったりする
で 先生が楽になりたくてすぐ暴力を振るう
体か言葉で   それで子供たちは当然怯える
怯えたら静かになる あ
これは楽やと と先生がそう思ってるでしょ
本当は子供たちに体か言葉で暴力を振るう先生が
本当は楽に物事を済ませたいんですよ
だって あるクラスの中で歩いている子供がいたらね
その子供になになに君
もうなんで君は座ってくれないのかとかね
なんか問題でもあるのかどうかね
それ話し合っちゃうと結構ややこしいでしょ
もしその子はあ 座りますけど
私はこの先生の授業は大嫌いし
先生も嫌いだから歩いても座れませんよと
次の授業で座りますよと言ったらどうする？そうする先生がどう対応すればよろしいか分からなくて困るでしょう
ややこしいでしょ 暴力振った方が楽なんですね
それでお釈迦様がこの方々は楽になりたいやと
だったら暴力振るなよと
それが本当の早道やとということで
非暴力の正しいやり方
お釈迦様は説くんですね
暴力の正しいやり方ではなく
非暴力を教えるんです
これが楽な道やと 例えば
学校の一人の子供がぐるぐるぐるぐる教室の中で歩いていると
君が勉強 今日勉強したくない
では 他の勉強したくない子供たちみんな立ってぐるぐる歩いてください
勉強したい子供たちだけ授業を聞いてくださいと言ったらどうなるんですかね
それはわからないんですよ
私がやったところでは
大体この言うこと聞かない子も恥ずかしくなっておとなしく授業を聞くことになりましたけど
そういう そういうことは頭にも浮かばないでしょう
一般の方々には はい それで一つ終わりました
それからいじめと社会現象という大きなテーマに入りまして
人間の人間らしさを問われるんです
人間にあなた人間ですかと聞かなくてはいけなくなっているんです
いじめというのはルールオブザジャングルなんです
この英語ぐらいはわかりますね
ルールオブザジャングル
いじめは獣の法則です
生物学的にホモサピエンスであっても
精神的に未熟な人間は
他をいじめることで自分の存在が成り立つという本能を持っています
我々は本当は形人間ですけど
心は獣です だから他の生命をいじめて暴力を振るったところで
自分の立場 存在が確立するんです
だから暴力を振るっちゃいます
人間は生まれてから妙術の人間に成長しなくてはならないんです
人間で生まれただけで万事解決じゃありません
生まれてから人間にならなくちゃいけないんです
生まれるのは形だけ これを本当の人間に作ってあげなくちゃいかないんですよ
社会にはその興味はない限り
この世界から人間が人をいじめることはなくなりません
しかし この言葉はこの世界ではないんです
人間で生まれただけで完全たる人間だと思っているんです
生物 ただのホモサピエンスでしょ
猿と何が違いますかね
それからですよ 別な立派な人間にならなくちゃいけないんです
これは動物世界ではないんです
動物は生まれてなんとか成長して
それでなんとかなんとか喧嘩して
まあ生きて死んじゃいますでしょ
我々もその程度で十分だと思っているんですね
大きくなって 学校に行って
勉強して 仕事をして まあ家作って
結婚して 子供作って まあそれからまあ死ねばいいということだけなんですね
だから獣の生き方とは全然変わってないんですよ
たとえ国連があったとしても
だから昨日ですね 国連のなんとか会議で
人権なんたら会議でスリランカを弾劾しちゃったんですね
人権を守ってないんだと
アメリカが 日本は一応棄権したんですね
と で この連中何者ですかね？あの国が誰の人権侵害しているんですかね
一般人誰でも好き勝手に裁判かける国ですけど
もう憲法裁判というものがあって
みんなかなり楽しく面白く生きてますけど
アメリカがテロリストいたんだから
テロリストたちがアメリカに行って金を儲けて
そういう金儲ける手段がなくなっちゃったんだから
アメリカの脳細胞ない連中動かしてね
この国を断言する弾劾すれば
またテロ行為できるだろうと
だからテロ行為を応援しながら生きてる連中でしょ
アメリカっていうのは
世界でテロがなければ
アメリカには儲かる手段がなくなる
他あるんだけど 一つとも手段が消えてしまう
それって人間のやり方？だからこの世の中はかっこつけてるだけで
中はみんな獣なんですね
成長していない だからブッダお釈迦様が言うのは
生まれたばっかしの生まれただけの心はもう獣の心で危険極まりのないものだと
これは着々と成長しなさいよと
お釈迦様はすごくわかりやすく
人間ではダメですよと言うんです
超越した人間になりなさいと
しかし 世の中はそうではなくて
獣を応援しているんですね
金持ちがすごいかっこいい
権力者が言うことは誰でも聞く
誰でも金儲かることこそ人生の目的だと
貯金の数字だけ上がって死ぬとき死んだら
その人成功したと そうですよ
どんな惨めに死んじゃっても構わない
死ぬ時の通帳の数字が結構あるとテレビで褒め称えていますよ
この人はこういうものを持っている
こういうものを持っている
こういうものを持っていると
では豪邸を訪問しましょうとかね
やはり豪邸に入って この玄関にあるこの絨毯は特注で
これだけにはどれ？これ高いでしょうね
あんま大したことはない
これは 1億 5,000万ぐらいですよとかね
絨毯だけでそんな ああ
びっくり とかね それを褒めるんですよ
だから世の中はみんなこの獣の生き方を応援しているんですよ
心を清らかにすることこそ人間
であると誰も言ってないんですね
だからこれ世の中はね
わかりやすく言えば ブッダの言葉は通じない限りは
世の中の暴力は消えません
強者生存 食うか食われるか
やるかやられるか 生きるか死ぬかが野生の規則ですね
ジャングルのルールっていうのはこれなんです
強者生存 食うか食われるか
やるかやられるか 生きるか死ぬか
本当に人間もその法則で生きているんだから
思考能力 判断能力 文化
社会制度 道徳などがある
人間はルールオブザジャングルに従う必要はありません
私たちには思考能力があるわ
判断能力があるわ 文化があるわ
社会制度があるわ 道徳があるわ
動物ないんですよ なのになんで
ジャングルの規則に従うんですかね
弱い者をいじめて自分の立場を誇示する
問題を暴力で済ませる
この人の心はまだ獣です
だから世の中で暴力を振るう側が
体罰を与える側が獣です
そんな必要ないんです
それでいじめる側について考えましょう
いじめる側には自信がない
精神的に不安 自分の存在を何とか確立しなくちゃいけないんですよ
自分の立場 価値観 欲 権限などを奪われると怯えているんです
野生と同じく戦わなくては
先に挑戦しなくては 先制攻撃しなくてはいけないんですね
本能から来る感情なので制御はできません
これこそ道だと思っちゃうんです
わかりますかね ちょっと言っていることはちょっと難しそうなんですけど
人がいる 自信はない 精神的に不安
自分の立場作りたい 自分も認めてほしい
自分の価値観としてほしい
自分の欲を理解してほしい
自分も権限欲しい これがなくなったらどうしようかと
例えば権力者がいますね
権力者の権力がなくなる可能性があったらどうする？暴力振るうんです
あの かつて今リビアではまあ壊れたんですけど
リビア政府はね  15年
20年  30年かな わからない
ガダフィという独裁者に支配された
だからガダフィとガダフィの家族だけですね
政府は すごい石油がありますよ
全部自分と家族だけで
なんで他の国民は立ち上がらなかったんですか
最近まで やっぱりガダフィは自分の権力を奪われるかもしれませんということで
徹底した暴力主義で国民をキュッと押さえていると
今どんな国でしたっけ？あの
え シリアでまだ独裁政権に対して国民とまたやってます
結局はあれも獣同士の戦いなんですけどね
で イラクにもね 独裁者がいましたし
で この独裁者が自分の権力はヤバイなあと思っちゃうんだから
すごい凶暴な 例えば中国ではもうちょっと一言葉政府に対して言っちゃったらすごい大変なことになりますね
なぜかというと 権力者があれほど権力を握っているのに
あれほど国の金を握って盗んでいるのに
怖いんですね 自分の立場が
だから暴力振るんですよ
これは野生の法則ですよ
野生では戦わなくては自分の立場がないんですよ
猿の群れで他のオス猿たちオス猿たちを攻撃して噛んで
勝たなくては自分がボスになりません
だから野生の群れで暴力振るわないオス猿はね
生きていられませんよ
交尾できません だからオス猿たちがやっぱり暴力を振る
戦う そこでかみつく 怪我もする
私たちの怪我とは違いますよ
猿がお互い噛まれて怪我したら
だってもう治療を受けないんですからね
診療所に行かないでしょ
それだけで動かなくなっちゃって死ぬ可能性もあるしね
同じことを我々人間みんなやってます
世界中で 暴力は必要だと
軍事力は必要ですと 軍事政権が必要ですと
面白いこと 世の中で軍事政権もあるんだからね
あれ どんな理屈ですかね
今ちょこっと微妙に変わっただけで
ミャンマーも軍事政権でしたし
あれ 仏教の国でしょ しかし
猿たちがいるんですね
猿たちが権力を握っちゃったら
人間はもう逃げるしかないんです
ミャンマー人は本当にすごい立派な人々なんですよ
大人しくて すごい道徳もあって
優しい人間なんですよ
でも 長い間軍事政権で暴力に抑えられてきてきてきたんですね
それから北朝鮮というね
あれは明確に軍事政権で
軍隊は力が強くなればなるほど国が豊かであるという解説までしているんですね
だから他の国々は GDP やらなんだらかんだらわけのわからないことで国の経済成長を計算するでしょ
GDP はどれぐらいですかとかね
一人当たりのなんだらかんだらいくらでしょうかとかね
それから貿易は赤字黒字どうですかとかね
そういう数字で国の経済状況
健康かないか診断するのに
北朝鮮は軍事力がこれぐらいありますから
我輩は世界一強いだと
国民一人当たりこれぐらい軍人がいるんだよと
国民一人当たり 3人軍人がいれば
これって豊かな国ですかね
じゃあ 胸を張って人間だと言える？だからブッダの暴力論ないんだから
私は暴力的に喋ろうと決めたんです
だから人間みんなまとめて
今暴力的な言葉を意図的に使って語っているんです
人権を守れ 守りなさいというアメリカ人は人間だと思う
国連は暴力組織じゃないと思う
結局全部暴力組織なんですよ
猿から進化したという話ですからね
猿から形が変わったんだけど
その他の進化はまだまだやってないんです
これがみんなの感情ですから
本能だから私が暴言吐いていると思っちゃうんです
本当のこの人は暴言やと
本当のことじゃないんだと
我々は立派やとそう思っちゃいますよ
自分の本能だから したがって
他を威嚇する いじめる
暴力を振るう 私たちは何やってますかって
仲間を威嚇しているだけなんですよ
情けないことをやってます
いじめているんです 暴力を振るっているんです
いじめられる側の話に入りましょう
例えばミャンマーだったら国民みんないじめられる側
で この場合も野生の法則が働いています
いじめられる側は人間になっているんですかね
精神的にないんです また同じ獣なんです
だからいじめられる側も
ジャングルのルールで生きてます
その人々は弱さを感じる
隠れたい気分になる また
強者を無視する いろいろするんです
シリアの国民も アメリカとNATOからずっといろいろもう援助をもらって
もう金のある国だから
これ壊せというまでじっと黙って待っていたんですけど
ということは 今まで弱みを感じて
我々は控えめで隠れて
国民は隠れていればなんとか生きていられるんじゃない？という感じなんですね
それで店もあるし 観光客も行ったり来たりするし
シリア人も外国に行ったり来たりもするし
大学にも行くし 勉強もするし
まあ普通に生活しているんです
しかし 権力はゼロ なし
選挙はなし 国の財産はほとんどシリアの独裁者の家族だけで
これで決まって私たちは弱いもの
大統領が強者 で落ち着いているって
それも野生の法則なんですね
猿の群れでボス猿がいるでしょ
また若手のオス猿たちもいるでしょ
みんな表に出ないんですよ
ボス猿が座って 他の猿たちも同じところで集まっている時でも
前に全部座っているのはメス猿たちだけですね
みんな子供を抱えて周り座って
まあボス猿のことをそんなにも気にしないで
普通にリラックスしている
オスたち猿たちはその後ろで自分たちでやんちゃで遊びながら喧嘩しながら生活している
だから赤ちゃん猿たちもどんどん
なんていうのは思春期とか
若者の猿になってくると
後ろの男の群れに入っちゃうんですね
そちらで弱き者の集まり
間違ってでも若手のオス猿がこの群れの間に行ったら大変危険なんです
ボスの前を通らなくちゃあかんだったら
これすごい危険なことなんです
時々通らなくちゃいけないんですよ
まあ森だから通るとこはちゃんとボスにものすごくおじぎをして礼をして通るんです
これで自分の身の安全を図るんです
それもジャングルのルールですよ
強者に従いなさいと 身の安全のために取る
この行動 無視するっていうこともありますね
日本人ではよくやりますね
学校で時々無視するっていうことがあってね
無視すると この強者をね
すごい危険なことになるし
無視して身の安全もできるし
関係ないことだから まあちょっと下がりましょうと
自分の安全のために取る
その行動は 相手の威嚇する精神をかき立てるんです
例えば 学校である子供が自分が弱いんだから
このすごい力強い友達のことは見ないでじーっといます
自分の机のところに座って
本を漫画の本しか読まないんだからね
漫画を見ながら 大人すぎるでしょ
強者を無視してるでしょ
それでこの連中がグループで来て
あの子供一人を囲まっていじめるんですね
何もやってないんです
お前気持ち悪いやとかね
学校に来るなよと あるいは 5,000円持ってこいとかね
いろんなことをやっちゃうんですね
それでこの強者の子供たちに
なんで暴力振るう暴力振るいたくなっちゃったんですかね
あれは無視なんですね
あの子の 弱い子にはいわゆる無視するしか取るべき態度がないんですね
こんにちは 仲間に入れてくれとは言ったっても入れてくれないし
あっち行けと言うんだから
わかりましたと あっち行って大人しくいるとやられちゃうんです
もう逃げる所ないんですよ
私も仲間に入れてくださいと言っちゃうと
お前こっちに来て入るなよと言っちゃうし
まあそう じゃあ私は一人で一人でいると
この野郎 我々を馬鹿にしやがってとかね
もう来るんでしょ？だから何なのかね
この世の中は 弱い者も結局は強者の威嚇本能をかき立てるんです
強者の社会組織と波長が合わないんですね
このいじめられる側の波長が合わないんですよ
この日本の学校では お前臭いや気持ち悪いやあれやこれやと言ってるでしょ
あれ 波長合わないんですね
波長が合わせる気も起きない
それで弱い者が何とかしてこの方々の気持ちに合うように生活しますとできない
それがいじめられます
獣から人間に成長しなくてはいけないんですよ
だからいじめる いじめる側もいじめられる側も心が獣ですね
いわゆる獣が取る体で取っているんです
野生の猿が取る態度をとっているんです
だから結果は強者であろう弱者であろう
いじめるいじめが現れる
いじめと社会はなんですかね
いじめは社会中あります
日本では社会的に組織的にいじめを寛容する傾向もあります
これもルールオブザジャングルです
単独生活する生き物は少ない
世の中で単独生活の生き物は少ない
皆 類の群れで生活します
生存 存続するために起こる現象です
ある群れの生き物に別な群れに変えることはほとんど不可能です
これなんで問題は 例えば猿がいるで
猿は群れでいますよ しかし
一個の群れじゃないんですよ
それぞれの群れがあるんです
ある群れの人口が増え
増えると別れるんですよ
新しいボスを作って分かれて別な引っ越しするんです
それで同じ猿だから 例えばある猿の息子がいます
しましょう 息子がもうこの群れでいられなくなって
こそこそと別な群れに入ったとします
その群れで生活していて
なんかたまたまお母さんにご挨拶にでも行きましょうよと言って入ったとしましょう
入れますか？入れません
攻撃受けます 噛まれます
追い出されます 入ったら攻撃を受けます
攻撃に耐えて群れに服従するならば入れてくれます
稀にありますよ 猿が群れを変えるという
我々は時々国籍変えたりするでしょ
あれと同じなんです 国籍変えるのはものすごい難しいんです
で 猿もたまたま稀にやりますね
別な群れでいている猿が
何のことなく そろそろそろそろと別な群れに入って
結構時間かかりますよ
日本はまあ日本人以外に国籍ありませんだけど
まあ厳しい群れですね
厳しい野生の群れですけど
アメリカでは アメリカでずっと十年ぐらい生活したならば資格取れるんです
グリーンカードをもらって
それから十年か五年 六年かわからないんだけどね
まあ日本でも十年という決まりはあるんですけど
やっぱり決定するのは二世
三世 白世なんですね まあ白世しか結局はまずいことになりますけど
冗談は置いといて まあ厳しいんですね
とにかく だからそれも野生のジャングルのルールなんですね
人間の間でも同じことをやっているんです
人間の場合は 家族という群れから社会
会社 学校などの群れに入らなくてはいけないんですね
人間がかわいそうですよ
一つの群れでずっといられないんですよ
だから昔よかったね あの原始時代では
人間が自分を生まれたお母さんのそのところでずっと死ぬまでいる
狩りをしながら 教育も学校も何もないし
自分いるところから出ていかないし
今そうじゃないんです
今も我々は原始群れがありますね
家族は原始群れなんですね
どうしようもないんですね
家族に子供が生まれるんだから
この子は別なところの人やと言えないでしょ
だから自分の群れの一員なんですね
そのそこまでは安全ですよ
子供が決していじめられません
大事にされます 可愛がってくれます
楽しいんです しかし 別な群れに入らなくちゃいけない
学校があります その群れはそう簡単に受けてくれない
入学という手続き 簡単ですけど
本当に学校に入れてくれるということには時間かかりますよ
これで地味が生じるんです
猿の社会と同じく 皆人間を装う精神的獣なので
いじめ 暴力 体罰は当たり前
服従を要求されます 学校の場合は
先生たちが服従を要求する
仲間が服従を要求するんですよ
これ理不尽だからうまくいかなくて
暴力だけ残るんです 猿
ゾウなどの動物 は群れを作る
同じ種類であっても 他の群れとコンタクトしない
人間は国 民族 組織 法人などの無数の群れを作るんです
同じ国であっても 例えばアラビア系のイスラム系の国々ではかなり争いがあるんですね
それはいろいろ民族なんですね
民族同士で殺し合いをやっているんです
だから同じイスラム教だからみんな仲良くしなさいと宗教家が言ってますよ
しかしそう言ってる宗教家もある部族ですからね
で 隣の部族を亡く殺すんです
言い訳するんですね イスラム教を守るためにやったと
ただの殺し合いだけなんですよ
だから人間の社会では群れがあるはあるは小学校ね
中学校とかあるでしょ
それからクラブあるでしょ
すべて群れなんですよ
群れ 群れは悪くない 野生でも群れを作らなきゃ生きていられない
猿も群れでなきゃ生活できません
しかし もともと野生だから威嚇しなきゃ立場がないということでやってますね
人間も だから人間のどんなクラブ作ったってもいじめがあります
大人の男たちがゴルフクラブとかね
ゴルフクラブ持ってゴルフクラブに行くでしょ
言葉のいじめとかないんだけど
微妙に威嚇はありますよ
見張ったり 威嚇はあります
群れの中での権力を争うこと
自分の立場を確定すること
群れに服従しないメンバーを裁いたり追放したりするのは規則なので
暴力 いじめ 嫌がらせ 足を引くなどが欠かせない
この世の中からは みんな簡単に解決したいと思っているんですけど
この世の中の問題はそう簡単に解決できません
はい 人間は教育を受けるべきです
成長していない心を真の人間になるまで正しく育てるべきという
私のポイントはわかるでしょう
私は人間とは人間よそ者というすごいかっこいい言葉で今講演をやっています
暴言ではないんです 優しい言葉です
仮免許と免許 人間として生まれる時は無免許です
社会秩序を学ぶこと 知識技術を身につくことで仮免許になります
思いやり 優しさ 助け合いなどを学んで経験して
人間だけではなく他の生命にも優しくすることなどで慈しみ中心の人間になったら免許です
この免許は誰も考えていない
人間になるために免許が必要
やと みんな仮免許で十分だと思ってるんです
根深い暴力 で うわべの現象を分析することでは暴力は消えません
暴力 いじめ 体罰などを完全に中止することは人間には考えられないんです
優しいだけではダメだと思っています
みんな 正しい体罰を考えているんです
どうやって正しい体罰はあるのかと
しかし 見当つかないんですよ
学校の問題どうしよう
いじめはどうしよう よく考えてるでしょ
何もわからないんですね
知識 文化 法律などのおかげで
ある程度で真面目な社会を作ってます
本当に我々はなんで殺し合いやってないんですかね
獣ですから やっぱり知識がありましてね
社会もありましてね 法
法律もありまして そこでちょっと制限されていますよ
人を殺してやりたいんだけど
やっぱり法律があるんだからね
やめちゃいます しかし
互いに競争する その代わりに競争する
喧嘩する 戦争もする 人間がいるところに必ず暴力的な生き方は存在する
人間がいるところに必ず暴力的な生き方は存在する
これは金言で覚えてください
どこかに人間がいれば
そちらに暴力があるんです
我々の知識はすべて仮免許に過ぎないのです
知識で解決しませんよ
知識人 いくら議論やっても
人間でしょ 暴力があるんで
その暴力に対策って練ってる人間も暴力振ってますよ
例えば たまたまチャンスがあって
そういう暴力に対する対策をどうしましょうかと練っている議論会に入ってみてください
入って何か言葉を発言してみてください
クタク呼ばれます あんた何者ですか？と
この方はテレビに出演している有名人でしょうにと
あれも暴力ですよ 暴力のない社会っていうのは
これははてなですよ 心が成長している社会です
もし社会の人間の心が成長しているならば
自我の錯覚を破って 理性に基づいて慈しみの気持ちで生きる社会です
そんなのないでしょ お釈迦様がサンガ組織を形成していく時は
社会が達するべき目標にするべき
サンプル 定番を作ったんですよ
サンガっていうのは出家の組織ですけど
そちらは暴力ないんです
簡単に理解できませんよ
これはもうまだまだ研究もしていない
なんでこのサンガ組織は 2100年も管理者もなくよく
続くんです 監督もなく
ですので 私にいたっても全く一人で生活していますよ
仲間は 0 ですよ 日本でみんなに嫌われちゃって
で 一人でいるんだから好き勝手にいるんですかね
いないんです ちゃんとしっかりと
で 私を誰も管理していないんだけど
これがすごいお釈迦様の群れの作り方なんですね
サンガは私の今日の用語を使っちゃえば一つの群れなんですね
まあうまく機能してないが
まあ結構いいサンプルなんですね
不可能を可能にする お釈迦様は欲
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ エゴ 無知などの感情で汚れている人々の心を清らかにしてみせる
人間の次元を破って超越した人間に聖者にして見せる
殺人鬼のアングリマーラさえ大阿羅漢に聖者にして見せたんです
999人人を殺したそうです
しかし聖者大聖者になっちゃったんです
お釈迦様は教育上 暴力を振ったのでしょうかと
だから学校の先生 大学の教授はこんなすごいことをやっていないでしょう
大学で優等生で卒業した人々も犯罪を起こしてるでしょ
この世の中で いくらでも
あんな先生じゃゴミみたいですよ
お釈迦様は対極すると
人を 10人殺した殺人鬼がいれば
皆様どうやって育てるんです？その人を
殺しちゃうでしょ そんな程度の能力でしょ
国王も軍人も軍隊も アングリマーラさんの名前を聞いただけで怯えたんです
国民が暴動を起こしちゃって
王がね 遊んで遊んでないでこの殺人鬼を殺してくださいと言ったら
王様がすべての軍隊をまとめて出て行ったんです
それぐらい一人の人間のことを怖がったんです
このエピソードで それでも王様が出て行きたくないんです
しかし お釈迦様が世の中に何か教えるチャンスであると言って
王様が行く前の日 あの森に一人で行ったんです
あの殺人鬼に会いに 行ったら殺そうとしたんですけど
お釈迦様は怯えませんだからね
憂いで反応しないんだから
できなかったんです この人は違うんだと言って話し合ったんです
話し合ったら その場で全て武器も全部捨てて
今までの生き方も全部捨てて
私を出家させてくださいと
いいですよと そのまま出家を認めて連れて行ったんです
で 次の日 朝 王様が出て行かなくちゃいけない
軍人 軍隊を で 王様は何か怪しいことを考えるんですね
軍隊を持って戦いに行くののに
まあとりあえずまずお釈迦様に礼をして行きましょうよと
お釈迦様と戦争は関係ないでしょうに
このからくりがあるんです
お釈迦様って戦争は嫌いだから
おそらく私に怒るでしょう
あんたね なんで軍隊を動かしてこんなもう人殺しに行くんですか？殺生ダメですよと言うでしょうね
言ったら私はまあしょうがない
皆の者よ もうお釈迦様に怒られましたから
帰りましょうよと いうからくりなんですよ
だから権力者の王はね
野生のジャングルオブルールオブザジャングルで考えれば不安なんですよ
自分の権力がなくなったらどうしようかと
だから威嚇しなくちゃあかんですね
この場合は威嚇なんかできそうもない状態
はい それで お釈迦様はたった 1 日でこの人を調教したんです
育ちました 育てました
お釈迦様は普通にああ
お釈迦様 なんか今日朝早すぎやと
またはあんた なんでこの鎧やらくだらんことを被ってくれるんですかと
実は王様はこういうこういうことで
こういうこういうことで
この言語は大変怒りになりまして
私はこれから戦いに行きますよと言ったら
お釈迦様はあのね この殺人鬼が
蟻一匹も殺さない 心清らかな修行をする
出家になっているならば
他の生命に慈しみを実践する出家修行者になっていれば
あなたはどうしますか？と
日本は政教分離という悲しい威張りげ
威張ってなんか誇り気に出し上がっちゃって
私の仏教活動に至るところで邪魔するんですけど
私は怒ってないんで 猿に怒ったって意味がないんだからね
で 普通は世の中はね 宗教ぐらいは人間の心の安らぎのために必要だと思いますよ
猿だけの文化はダメやと
アメリカは形だけ政教分離で憲法であるんだけど
みんな憲法を犯してるんです
宗教とがっしり合体しないと選挙に出られないんです
アメリカでも  それは雑談で
で 王様はあのね お釈迦様は宗教と政教は分離やと
政教分離だと 関係ないよ
そんなのはと言ってないんです
それならお釈迦様 彼が出家になって真面目に修行して
蟻一匹も殺さない人間になっているならば
私が守ってあげます 国として宗教を守るのは国の仕事の一つなんです
私が面倒見てあげます
食べ物やら住むところやら着るもののことで
で 約束するんです ああ
そうですかね ただ お釈迦様は国王を手で捕まるんですよ
人を触らないんで お釈迦様は
ケースはないんで そんな
こちらから取ったんです
取って側に座ってた比丘を見せたんです
あのね このアングリマーラっていうのはこの人ですと
それでこちらでお釈迦様取っているでしょ？王様ものすごくビシッとビビっちゃったんです
でもお釈迦様に捕まってるんだからバレなかったんです
誰にも 軍人にも だからお釈迦様はすごいんですよ
ここは腰に貸ししてるんですよ
守ってあげたんです それぐらい能力あった教育者
ブッダが教育上暴力振ったんですかね
これでしょ ポイントは
だからみんな仏教嫌い
だから猿たちに入らないんですよ
仏教は 成長したくないんだから
わかりやすい話でしょ
答えお釈迦様は持っているんです
この地球上でどんな人間にも
100人もものすごく残酷に殺した残虐者を完全な心清らかな人間にすることはあり得ないでしょ
お釈迦様はやってみせたんです
方法さえ正しければ何でもできますよと
だから 暴力を取り消す方法はブッダしか持ってないんです
そういうわけで 人の育ち方を学びましょうか
これはいくらか私のある程度で慣れている世界でもありますね
心の法則を知ってしつけをする
ただ教えるだけじゃなくて
心の法則 あの教育でも心理学とかなんだらね
エデュケーショナルサイコロジーとかなんだかくだらんことありますけどもね
あんまりもう発展してないみたいしね
仏教心理学も何とかやりやすいんですね
まず 脳の働きでみましょう
体罰 痛めつけ 暴力 非難
侮辱 いじめ 嫌がらせ 無視などのことで脳は開発しません
脳にそういうものをインプットすると開発しません
やっているでしょう 最初からの失敗の教育者なんです
萎縮するんです 脳は 脳は発展するべきところは萎縮しちゃうんです
心は獣のままで硬くなるんです
だからオックスフォード大学出たっても獣です
東大出ても獣は獣です
ハーバード出ても大したことはないんです
もうちょっと狂暴な獣だけです
わかりやすく言えばね
有名な大学に入ったら
ちょっとレベル高い狂暴になるだけですよ
獣は だってこれでやられちゃいますからね
私はハーバード卒業だと
これまた優等生でしたよとか言っちゃうと怖いでしょ
何も知らない生命として生まれる人間は
本物の人間になるまで
人の脳を丁寧に慎重に心理学的に開発するんです
遊びじゃないんです まず
私が先生だったら 私のところに人間装った猿が来るんですよ
この人間装ったこの猿さんを本当の人間にしてあげなくちゃあかんですよ
いい加減蹴ったり踏んだりしていいわけじゃないでしょ
これ大変な仕事なんですよ
これでこの猿の群れでね
もう噛んだり喧嘩したりいじめたり
何やこれはと 喜びが栄養剤
脳に喜び 充実感 褒め 認めなどなどのポジティブの栄養を与えなくてはならないんです
脳に栄養を与えないと
それも本人が自分自身でフィードバックするのは正しいやり方です
あんたね 笑って笑ってと言ったよりは
本人が笑っちゃうと本物ですよ
例えば人の顔 はい 笑って笑ってと
口元を広げて広がって広がってください
あれで本当に笑ってますか？相手が
逆に怒る可能性もあるでしょ
そういうわけで 心に喜びっていうのは
自分でフィードバックしなくちゃあかんですね
ご飯は用意するんだけど
本人がナイフとフォークを取って食べなくちゃいけないんです
食べさせちゃうとすごい失礼なんです
イメージしてください
皆様はフランス料理屋に行きました
ちょっと高いところに
それですごいナイフフォークも才能高もの
重くて 結構 それで あの
何といいますか お世話する係の人がね
来て あの あの あれ ナプキンはこうやってシュッと吸ってつけるのはかっこいいんですね
あいつらなんかちょっとこうやって吸って
まあ膝にかけてくれるでしょ
そこまではかっこいいんだけど
料理持ってきたらね はい
これはまあ なんだらかんだらとかね
言って それからちょっと待ってくださいと
本人がフォークを取っ
て こういう風に食べますよ
はい あーっと食べさせちゃうと
かっこいい この場合はこのフォークを使いますよとか
こんな風に取りますよと
はい  もう裁判に訴えたくなるぐらいでしょ
あの侮辱は そういうわけで
たとえその人がプロであっても
これはやってはいけないんです
だから 脳に喜び 充実感
褒め 認め が栄養です これは用意してください
食べさせないでください
それが教育の 何といいますか
ゴールデンルールなんです
だから私は教育では結構成功しまって
どんな生徒でも教えちゃうと
もう簡単 満点にしてみせる
絶対負けません 私は で
お釈迦様の教育方法でやります
脅し いじめはないんです
で 周りの仕事はやり方を教える
見守ってあげる 気が落ちたら応援する程度ですよ
しかし 相手を 我が命のように慈しみの気持ちが教育者に
応援者に必要です このからくりできるのは
相手のことを慈しむ時だけなんですね
お母さんにもこれできないんですね
教育は お母さんのこと
子供は可愛いと思ってるんだけど
愛着なんですね あれで人権侵害なんですね
子供の 学校と同じなんですね
学校の場合は愛着もないし
こいつら迷惑やと思ってるんだから教育できないんです
母親にもできない 失格です
慈しみが欲しいんです
これは人権を持っている人間です
でも今は君はね ただ装ってるだけよと
だから結構私は子供たちによく言ったことありますよ
あんたね 人間じゃないよと
時々一緒に仲間やと言って
一緒にあれこれやと要求するんですよ
じゃあ私も私もと 私はいきなり
ちょっと待った あんた人間じゃないよ
これは人間だけ使うものですと
だから怒るんだけど あれはもう可愛い怒りなんですね
だから私も可愛いんだから意図的に怒らせるだけでいじめじゃないんです
しかし 子供は可愛がるために私があんなことを言うんだけど
その中で嘘言って遊んでるわけじゃないんです
人間じゃないんです それである子は怒って
では私は何やと まあもう困ったな
まあじゃあ半分 なりかかっているということにしましょうかと
これに負けないでね そんなことは違うでしょうとか言ってくるんですね
私は人間やといけないです
あのね あんた運転できる？選挙に参加する
酒飲める で 黙ったんです
ほら なりかかってるだけやと
で そうやってもう無理やりに
違法的に私は勝ちますけどね
違法的に勝つのもまた楽しいんですよ
しかし そういうことでも私はある教育しているんです
遊びながら だから子供は知らないんですよ
自分で楽しんでるんです
楽しんでるのに成長するんです
ブッダの教育に入りましょうか
教育について これもこれぐらい十分でしょ
まだありますよ 膨大ですよ
教育論も 仏教教育論も
それも具体的な例で喋るとすごい大量です
お釈迦様は優しく 厳しく
優しく また厳しくという 3つの方法で教育するんです
わかってますね やっぱりね
やっぱりね お釈迦様もね
厳しくやってますね じゃあ見てみましょう
しかし このやり方は我々の想像と違います
人の成長のみを目指して仏教心理学的に行う教育で
それは だから この厳しくという言葉は
お釈迦様も我々みたいに宿題やらないと怒るだろうと思ってるでしょ
ではないんです 性格をチェックして
心を開いてくれる方法を発見してアプローチするんです
お釈迦様の場合は まずこの猿さんがどんな性格ですかと見るんです
あ こういう風に こういう風に
こういう風にできているんだと
だって 親によって脳の働き
システム変わってるんですよ
各家族 家族でどんな育ち方をするかわからないでしょ
6年生みんな同じってわけでもないんです
同じでありながら違うんですね
で そこでこのどうやってこのちっちゃな猿たちの脳の部品ができているのかと
いわゆるチェックするんですね
いわゆる部屋の品物チェックなんですよ
部屋を美しく インテリア的にインテリア的に整理整頓してあげたいんですよ
荷物を まず荷物チェックでしょ
これやるんです ブッダはだいたいまあ
2 3秒で行います だから叶わないんです
で 方法は我々仏教徒たちにもすごく教えていますから
まあ我々ももうなんとなくなんだらかんだらでわかりますが
あれほど上手じゃないんです
人の脳という家をね 整理整頓して
インテリア的に美しいものにしたければしたいんだけど
まず荷物チェック それからどんな荷物から整理するのかと
これからチェックするんです
それでポジティブフィードバックアンドハピネスということになりますね
まず これは優しい方法です
どのように生き どのような生き方をすれば
どのような行為をすれば
心をどのように制御管理すれば幸福になるのかと教えるんです
これは人間を育てることだからね
学校じゃないんだから
ブッダは 人間装ってる猿を人間にすることだから
こういう風に教えるんですよ
こうした方がいいよとかね
こんな生き方ではすごくいいよとかね
言葉を喋る時はこういう風に
こういう風に喋りましょうよと
楽しいでしょ そういう言葉は
と うん 楽しい そうすると聞いた人も楽しいでしょ
だから愛語喋りましょうよ
愛語を教えて推薦する
人を助けることを教えてくれる
人を助けろではなくてね
助けられるとね 気持ちいいでしょ
だから人を助ける時もね
やっぱり相手喜ぶんだからね
あれって結構気持ちいいよ
だから人を助けましょうよ
これは気持ちいい そんなアプローチ
で教えていくんです まず
これは優しいやり方なんです
で 心理学的に言えば 脳にポジティブインフォメーションフィードバックされているんです
ポジティブ情報を与えているんです
で 脳がもう栄養たっぷり成長するんです
期待を与える 脳に これこれはね
あんたまだやってないんだけど
一個一個やってみとよ
これぐらいのことありますからね
やがてこうなっちゃいますよと
これは経典読んだって皆様には発見できませんよ
あります なんでかっていうと
経典はすべて解脱修行に当てはめてありますからね
そこを外さなければいないとシステムは見えないんです
まあ例えばね まあ人に物事を与えたり
ものを与えたり 人を助けてあげたり
親孝行したり 義務を果たしたりするとね
この世であんた最高よ
幸せでしょ みんなに褒められますよと
これできますよ あんたにも期待でしょ
脳はポジティブを期待してるでしょ
次にそれだけじゃないよ
あんた死ぬでしょ やがて死んじゃったら天国は待ち構えていると
それであんた天国は知らないでしょ
いて天国の話するんです
お釈迦様はそっちの関係持ってますからね
毎日のように神々が来て
お釈迦様と対話するんだから
だからじりじりとお釈迦様は現場状況を生放送してあげるんです
それで心が期待 期待 期待
他宗教の天国の話と違います
ブッダの天国の話は これは現場から生放送だから
お釈迦様は 期待 期待 期待に膨らませちゃったところで
頑張りますよ その人はすごい軽々と
このやり方ですよ やり方です
脳は刺激を受けて教えられたようにする
次 反対 ネガティブフィードバックアンドワーニング
これいじめではないんです
俗世間 獣の世間ではいじめです
体罰です 聖者の世間ではネガティブフィードバックアンドワーニングなんです
ワーニングというのは
なんで英語 英語にしたかというと
これ あの まず私はこのカタカナ書けないんです
ネガティブってどうやって書くのかさっぱりわからないんです
だからこの日本語でもネガティブ
ポジティブとありますけど
私はカタカナ発音もできないし
書けないんだから そうなってくると
もういいや もうめんどくさいんだから英語で書いちゃうということにするんです
例えばフィードバックも日本語のカタカナ語でしょ
フィードバックです ね
これだけはできますけどね
それから次のポイントはワーニングなんですね
ワーニングといってのは
この正しくなく 英語で言えばこのアウェアネスなんですね
だからアウェアネスという単語が仏教用語で瞑想に使っちゃいますから
みんな誤解 誤解する だからビーウェアなんですね
だからビーウェア そうするとあまりにも英語に入りすぎだからやめました
まあただこういう風にしました
で ネガティブフィードバックアンドワーニング
これ激しい教育 これは暴力でも体罰でもありません
脳が怠けると脳に危険信号を与えるんです
未熟な生命に生存欲があります
生きていきたいと まだまだお猿さんですよ
お釈迦様に弟子入りしたのは
まあ人間装ってるお猿さんなんです
出家してもお猿さんなんです
猿さんだから存在欲があるんですよ
生きていきたいと お釈迦様はそこにお釈迦様の放射線を当てるんです
お釈迦様はなんか放射治療みたいなもんなんです
釈尊は悪行為とその悪果を教えて納得させるんです
それでお釈迦様はダメと言わない
こら 怠けるなよと 何のことなくね
あのね これ怠けがあるでしょ
これ怠けがあるとこうなっちゃって
こうなっちゃって こうなっちゃって
こんな結果になっちゃって
こんな大変なことになっちゃって
みんなに嫌われちゃって
死んじゃったらまた地獄に落ちますと
言うとウォーニング危険信号
自分の脳があ 私はそんなのは嫌や
生きていきたいやと これでざーっと目が覚めるんです
脳は これチェックしてやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
いつでも悪いところばっかり言うんでもなく
いいところばっかり言うんでもなくて
脳のバランスを見ながら
ポジティブフィードバックかネガティブフィードバックかでしょうか？としなくちゃいけないんです
心は危険を感じて働き出します
そこで 3番目の方はミックスフィードバック
優しく厳しく 脳も波打ちます
たまにいるんですよ 人間が随分端色
人間が性格は この人を優しくすれば成長するんだと
この人に厳しくすれば成長する
あまりにも端色ですね
でも人間端色じゃないんですね
性格は だからこのミックスフィードバックが必要なんですね
優しく厳しく 脳も波打ちます
感情に抑えられたりもします
やりたいができない時もあります
やってみてもうまくいかない時もあります
やらなくてはいけないのに
つい反対のことをやってしまうことがあります
いろいろあるが やるかやらないかっていう 2つですね
気持ちで言えばいろいろですよ
皆様にも子供を育てた経験があればわかるでしょう
子供はもう何かやりたいと思っているのに
反対のことをやってしまっちゃったとかね
あるいは断言でやりたくない
やりたくないと言ったりする時もありますね
あるいはやるんだから後でやりますよ
母ちゃんという場合もあるでしょ
あれ 心の波なんですね
しかし 波は様々ですけど
結果で見てください やってるかやってないかなんです
言い訳どうであっても
やってるかやってないか
反対のことをやっている場合はやっているんですけど
反対のこと それでチェックして
ただやる やるときにもランクがあって
やらない気持ちにもランクがあります
これね 問題はね やる気がありますか？と言ったら
ランクありますよ やる気はやる気ありますけどねとかね
ありますよというのもね
いろいろランクがあります
じゃあまあやります というね
で やらない時でもね いろいろ気持ちのランクがありますね
絶対これだけはいや やりませんということもあって
まあいやですから なんとか逃げる方法ないかなと考えることもあって
またまあそのうちやりますとかね
ギリギリになったらやればいいでしょうとかね
そういう風にやりたくないことも
があります その時の気持ちに合わせてポジティブフィードバックかネガティブフィードバックアンドウォーニングかやらなくちゃあかんです
教育者は だからやりたがっているんだけど
やる気がレベル低い この時はかなりフィードバック
たくさん栄養をあげるんです
やる気満々の場合は黙っている
栄養をあげません そこでまあやりたくないんだけど
頑張っている で その場合はもうネガティブフィードバックですね
やりたくない気持ちが強いんだったら
あのねと言って ネガティブフィードバックをざーっとしてあげてるんですね
そうすると甘ったれではいられなくなっちゃいます
かすかなかすかな嫌でやっていると
あのね これではそれだけで十分です
これではそれだけで十分ですね
こういう風に計算しながら計算しながら
学生さんに師匠がこの気持ちをフィードバックするんです
脳に 教えそのものはすごい簡単というかね
そんな大げさなものじゃないんです
数学を教えるのは大げさなことじゃないんです
数学を理解して 数学者にしてあげるところで
このフィードバック それが本物の教育なんです
それからお釈迦様に捨てられる人間もいます
4番目います 捨てる人というか
捨てられる人なんです
教育者から言うんだから捨てる人
いかなる方法を駆使しても反応しないの
心もあります 何やってもダメな心
脳もありますよ 獣次元で止まっているのです
人間様々だからね で 脳っていうのは肉体でしょ？肉塊を持って生まれるんだけど
これはもう獣の次元で成長が進化が止まっている
例えば猿に日本語を教えられないでしょ
赤ちゃんの時から買ってあげたっても喋れませんね
脳が固定しています そのように人間にもそういうケースが起きます
成長は可能ですが 脳は獣状態に満足している時も教育は無理です
人間としては健在ですけど
本人が満足している獣で
これでいいやと 俺は暴力団のボスになりましたし
何が文句あるのかと 金もあるし
家来いっぱいいるし と思ったら
仏教的な いわゆる獣脱出教育はできない
この満足するところなんです
別に暴力のボスに仏教できないわけでも宗教できないわけでもないんです
あんた満足しちゃったらアウト
失格 獣に満足しちゃったら失格
それで落第 その人は捨てます
無駄に骨を折らないで
その人を捨てるんです
両者も苦労しないで済む
それが不親切な行為じゃないんですよ
吾輩は満足やと 暴力のボスで
何の問題もないぞと威張ってる人に私が言ってね
あのね 禅の瞑想しましょうよと言う
そうすると私は苦しいでしょ
殴られるかもね 殴られて追い出される
引っ張って 水をかけられるかも
何されるかわからない
それはやらなかったならば
この人は このボスって嫌だな
毎日毎日もう嫌なことばっかししちゃってって
本人も苦労するでしょ
ですから この捨てることは親切な行為です
両者は苦労しないで済む
で 人間の 4分の1を捨てる意味ではありません
だから  4種類の教育だから
人間の 4分の1捨てなさいということじゃないんです
文明社会に入れたがらない原始人のような存在は捨てられます
最近発見したことがありまして
あの経典で このナガ族のナガ族の人々を出家させないでと命令があるんです
出家禁止命令 インドのナガ族
私はこれ人種差別でしょうとかね
と疑問を持っていたんですね
理由は書いてますよ 生活習慣が悪いと
文明的じゃないんだと
食べ 食べ方 歩き方 座り方
すべて違うんだと 仏教の出家っていうのは
ものすごい文明的な品格を要求するんです
食べる時でもたくさん戒律ありますよ
こういうふうに食べなさいとか
だから だからやめましょう
だから私はそれでも 禁止はちょっと人権問題だなと思っていたんですね
これ最近インターネットでヒンドゥー教のあらゆる祭典やらね
ヒンドゥー教を勉強していたんです
それで十年一回起こるクンバメラーについていろいろ論文を読んでみたんです
それで 優秀な世界的なジャーナリストの方々は
クンバメラーに参加する人々は結構インタビューして
その人の人々の話もあったんです
このヒンドゥー教のクンバメラーに参加するサードたちの話を聞いてから
ああ なるほど わかった
やっぱりあなた方はこの捨てられる人間だと
これでやっとこの年になって
お釈迦様は人権侵害してなかったと発見したんです
結構時間かかっちゃったんです
あの連中は連中と言って失礼ですね
あの方々はね で 昔からもこの仏教を破壊するために
なんかヒンドゥーバラモン人に育てられたようで
カースト低いんですよ
いわゆる追い出されているんですね
だから野蛮的ですから
お前ら野蛮だからあいつを非難しなさいと
それであなた方の立場を認めてあげる
それがあなた方の修行であって
神のあなた方の功徳であると言ったら
誰でも宗教を信仰したいでしょ
これやっているんですね
だから破壊活動すること
仏教は品格だから 品格に完璧反対の生き方をするんです
あのインタビューで みんなこの上のない聖者たちで威張ってるんですよ
しかし みんな素っ裸なんです
ヒンドゥー教はなんで素っ裸ですか？あれ
ジャイナ教でしょ ジャイナ教は教理学的に一切装束束縛しないということで裸になるんです
ヒンドゥー教には関係ないんです
欲を認める宗教です そこでサードになる場合は
まずみんな服を全部脱がして
あの生殖器官に何かわからないやり方を見せてないんだから
なんか殴るみたいですね
殴ったらそれ機能しないんですね
それから まあわかりやすく言えば
手術も何もなく なんて言いますか
キャストレートしたような感じなんですね
キャストレートしませんだけど
神経が機能しなくなっちゃいますと
これもおかしいやと思いますけど
真面目に信じて裏で結構やっていると思いますけど
で それから聖者たちはみんな拝んだりいろいろして
それからこれぐらい太いハシシ
みんなこんな太い長いハシシのあれ
タバコ ハシシばっかりですよ
巻いてすわすわすわすわ必死で
それから回す 大変です
だからやっぱりわかったんで
捨てられる人もいるんだと
で 漁獲災害を起こした人々は無理です
で 脳に異常があってやむを得ず暴力行動する人も
治療不可能なら教育も無理です
で 暴力振るっていうのは
もう人間として失格者のメダルですよ
まあ言わなくたっても猿ということですね
で 理解能力がない 慈しみがない
落ち着きがない 人を育てることより自分の業績を上げること
職業安定を先に考える
考えられる側が初めからも不完全で
教えられる側が初めから不完全で言うことを聞かない生命体であることを忘れている
子供は初めからわがままと忘れていますね
簡単に済ませたいという怠けがある
で その人は必ず暴力を振るう
仏教は非暴力論です 体罰
暴力 いじめは完全に中止するものです
非暴力論 生命は平等です
誰にも他を裁く権利も
体罰を与える権利もありません
すべての生命は幸福を得たいするから
それを与えるか案内するかすることは生きる生きている生命の義務です
行為の結果 各個人が必ず受けるので
悪行為をする人を暴力で抑えて自分も罪を犯す必要はありません
で これは英語で書いてましたから
We always blame others, but we do not blame ourselves
ね これは仏教用語 ブッダの言葉で
ネパレーサンウィローマーネパレーサンカタカタン
アッタナオアヴェッケイヤ
カタニャカタニチャ 他の過ち
なしたことをなさなかったことは結構です
自分が何をしているか
何をしていないのか観察すること
暴力が消えない理由はこちらにあります
人に指を指す 自分には指さない
これだけなんです 自分にも指してみてよと
人類はを被告人にするんですかね
だから人に指を指すということは
私が全人類が被告人にしているんです
だから裁いたいんです
他の人も私に指を指してます
自分に指を向けなさいよとお釈迦様は言うんです
だから暴力っていうのは人類被告人にすることですよ
言うことを聞かない人
秩序和合を守らない人
決まり規則に従わない人
法律を犯す人 罪を犯す人
自分に気に入らない人を批判したい
裁きたい 罰を与えたい
戒めたい 自分のことを棚に上げる
この生き方も問題です
人は不完全なので 先輩が後輩に手を伸ばして助けるのは自然法則です
人類を自然法則を守らないで他を訴える
短所ばかり探す 一人が一人一人がかな
一人が自分の義務を  これ一人一人がですね
一人一人が自分の義務を果たすならば
後から生まれてくる者も問題を起こしません
子供たちが悪いのは我々の責任がありますよ
で 成長不可能なハンディを持って生まれる人以外
皆育てられます  4番目捨てる人間以外は
ただ 世の教育基本は欲
利益 競争 バイオレンスであり
慈しみはない これが問題です
脳に心に慈しみを注入すれば人格は向上するし
この世から暴力が消えます
終わりです どうもありがとうございます
ちょっと2分3分経過しました
最後に皆さんで香の御前で終了したいと思います
合掌してください 香登も仏法僧の参謀に礼拝し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サッビーティヨヴィバンジャントウサンバローゴーウィナッサトーマーティーバワッタンターラーヨースッキーディーナユコーバワーバウトゥサッブマングラッカン
トサンバデーヴァタサンバブンダヌバーヴェーナサンバダンマヌバーヴェーナサンバサンガヌバーヴェーナサダーすってーバワントゥティーアビワダナシーリーッサー
ニッチャンワンダパチャイノーチャッターローダンマーワンダンティーヤーイワンノーシュカンバラン
サーリプッタサーリプッタサーリプッタ
はい ありがとうございます
はい